- OK, a lot of season left, but are you
the MVP?
- Me the MVP?
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah, I came in this season thinking
I was the MVP.
♪♪♪
- DeMar, what up?
- Tay, what's going on?
- Nothing, it's good to see you.
- Always, always.
- Now, you know, last time I saw you,
your hair was much shorter.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. It was a lot shorter.
Yeah.
- So things have changed.
- Yeah.
- Why did you decide to grow it out?
- I don't know. I just got lazy.
- Yeah?
- Just stopped getting a haircut.
Just let it grow and…
Just really just let it grow.
- Yeah.
- Honestly.
- It's funny because that's
how all these things happen.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's, like, either you couldn't
find a good barber,
- Mmhmm.
- You wanted to get the braids.
- Yeah.
- Or you're like, "I'm just done dealing with this, so
I'm gonna grow it out."
- Just let it, let it go.
- Yeah. It looks good, though.
- Then I started liking it, so I kept it, so.
- Yeah, so you found a good braider
in Chicago?
- Yeah.
- OK.
- I got—yeah. Or sometimes I'll fly
who does my hair from home just to come
braid my hair.
- Oh. Must be nice.
- I know it sounds bougie, but yeah.
- [Laughing]
Oh, no, no, no. You gotta do what you
gotta do.
- Nah, yeah. I got to, got to.
- To have the right person—
- You got to.
- Doing your hair.
I'm really happy that I got to see you,
though, for myriad reasons.
But one thing is I have a bone to pick with you.
So on my show that we did,
what, like, two years ago,
- It was like, yeah…
- Two-and-a-half years ago?
You revealed that you rap.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- And you told me you was gonna
give me the song
when you decided to put a song out.
- I did. You right. You right. You right.
- The song is out.
- Yeah.
- What happened?
- I put—it was, that song was such a, like,
in the moment, like, my man Problem,
one of my close friends that rap,
we was in Vail, Colorado,
and it was, like, 2:00 in the morning.
And he was just, like, "Let's record a song
and put it out tonight."
And we literally recorded a song
and put it out that night,
like, in real time. Like…
- Yeah.
- And I didn't think nothing about it.
That was my only chance to put a song out.
- OK.
- It was in that moment, you know what
I mean?
- Yeah.
- I just put it out, and it was cool. It was…
- So it was a small window.
And if you didn't do it—
- Yeah, yeah. If I didn't
do it then, it wasn't gonna happen.
- Yeah, but still—
- Wasn't gonna happen.
- Only one song's out.
- Yeah, it's only one song.
And what's crazy,
we have a video to it too. Like—
- Is that coming out?
- I'm thinking about it. I'm
thinking about putting it out.
- What would sway you
to, "Yes, it's coming out"?
- I don't know.
I gotta be in the, I gotta find
that same moment I had that night.
- Yeah.
- I gotta find it one of these days,
and I'll put it out. But we got one.
- You know, we had Lou Williams on the show
last season, and he said the same thing
about having music.
He's like, "No, if I wake up
in the mood, sure."
- Yeah.
- "But I'm very rarely in the mood."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "But when it comes, I'll decide to,
you know, bless you all—"
- Yep, yep.
- "With this music."
What was the feedback on that song?
- It was great. I mean, it was a lot of surprises
because people didn't expect me to ever
put a song out or hear me on a song.
And for the most part, it was dope.
You know, some of my closest friends
that do know that I rap
called me and was like,
didn't believe I even put out a song.
But even though they hear all my songs,
they were just shocked
that I put a song out,
so it was cool.
- Yeah, any good feedback?
I know when we spoke,
you said, like, Kendrick Lamar has heard
your music,
- Yeah.
- Drake's heard your music.
- Did they hear the one you released?
- I'm pretty sure they did.
I haven't heard no feedback for it.
- Oh, OK.
- But, yeah, yeah.
- Hey, it was a good beat.
I was jamming to it,
you know?
- Yeah, it was just a moment.
It was a moment.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- But I say all that to say,
like, time moves so quickly.
- Fast.
- So much has changed
from when I last saw you to now.
So if you look back to that moment, right,
it was, you were playing
with the Spurs.
- Mmhmm.
- Raptors in the Eastern Conference Finals.
We were just talking about life—
- Mmhmm.
- And everything you had been
through up to that point.
If you think about that moment
and if you titled kind of that season
of your life, what would you call that?
And what would you call this
one you're in now?
- Um, man,
growing, you know?
That moment then, you know, I was
in a tricky place mentally,
emotionally, dealing with obviously
being traded, going to a new situation.
Just, like, everything started to move
fast but slow down at the same time for me.
For me, just kinda to lock in
and kinda get out of my comfort zone
with basketball and with life
and just try to figure out what direction
I wanted to grow in.
You know, and that was kind of
the perspective I started to take from there
and stopped looking at everything so negative
and just take everything
in stride and learn from it
and grow from it
from then on. And look
where I'm at now, so.
- Absolutely. So
that would be titled "growing."
- Yeah.
- This is titled?
- [Sighing] This is titled…
What they say, it's like…
That's a good one.
I wish I would have
had some great comeback for that one.
- Lil' bar ready?
- Yeah, I think now it's just more so,
just,
you know, growing and continuing
to manifest the things that, you know,
that you want in life, you know what I
I mean? You know, we always try to
strive for the success with, you know,
things on the basketball court,
personal life, professional life.
But just manifesting everything,
you know, a positive mindset.
Mental approach to everything.
You know, it's tricky times we live in.
You know, when we last talked,
you know, we weren't dealing with—
- Yeah.
- What we dealing with
now in the world, you know? And,
you know, just consistently
trying to figure out
how to be that, you know, spark
to the world that can help,
you know, with positivity
more than anything.
I think we all need it,
because it's very tricky times
right now.
- 100 percent.
Well, I do have to say this about you.
Any time someone says
anything about you ever,
they talk about how nice and kind you are.
- Yeah.
- I'm sure you know that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But you leave, like, a very good footprint with
everybody that you come in contact with.
- Yeah.
- So, I'm sure all those things that you
wanna do in terms of being positive
for people, you were already doing it.
And doing it now in Chicago.
- Yeah.
- Which—thank you for bringing us here
because this is one of my favorite cities.
You gotta get Harold's Chicken.
- Everything, yeah.
- You gotta get Sunda.
You gotta get all the things.
So, happy that you're here in Chicago now.
Are you enjoying the city?
- Yeah, I love it.
Can't even find the words at times.
You know, it's such a
great situation
off and on the court.
You know, you're playing in Chicago.
- Mhmm.
- One of the best sports cities in the world.
You know, the culture, the history
behind it, everything that come with it.
So to be part of that, to be thriving
at a high level is an honor.
It's definitely an honor.
And it's fun, you know?
- Yeah.
- You can see it when we go out there and
play as a team. For me personally,
you know, it's obvious.
- Yes, it's a huge, you know, sports city.
But the Bulls, they haven't
been to the postseason since 2017.
Haven't been to the Eastern Conference
Finals in 10 years.
When you hear that, what do you think?
- I love the challenge.
You know, that was my whole reasoning
even coming here was to take
on all those challenges
of what they haven't done,
what they couldn't do.
Um, dealing with all the doubt.
You know, you always wanna
take on challenges
and prove the naysayers wrong.
You know, and as a competitor, you know,
you want those things. You know, that was
part of my motivation to come
here. Every guy on the team, motivation.
So, you know, that's
definitely what we striving for.
- When you looked at the Bulls,
what are the things
that you saw as challenges
and what are the things that you saw,
"Oh, like, this is good.
I can work with this."
- Um, the challenges was,
you know, the culture is kind of,
you know, they haven't won, like you said,
in a few years.
They've been a team
that's, you know, been a lottery team, you know?
You know, for me, I looked at the team,
and me being a fan of
Zach LaVine his whole career,
you know, looking at his career,
understanding what
it's like to be in a moment that he was
in, not winning, wanting to win,
wanting to get to the postseason
and being an All-Star.
You know, not being appreciated
like he should with his talent
that he have. We want to be
a part of that and help that.
Help the organization, help the city.
You know, I think to see—the league
thrives at a high level when a Chicago
team is at the top of the league,
you know? And you see it now.
And those are the challenges
and things that I looked at
before I even make my decision.
So, in the midst of me looking at it
that way, you know, you added Lonzo Ball,
Alex Caruso, you add all these key players,
Vucevic, to the team,
that made it even more intriguing.
- Yeah. Well, remember when everyone said,
"Hey, how are they—
there's two ball-dominant guards. How's it gonna work?"
- Yeah.
"Where are they going to get the defense from?"
- Yeah. I love that. I hear it all, and I love it.
You know, like I say, as a competitor,
you hear it and you
laugh at it
when you know the preparation that you putting in to prove
everybody wrong.
- What have you proven
this year so far?
- Um, in my mind, nothing yet.
You know? Nothing yet.
You know, but I've proven to myself that I
can be happy again
playing basketball, you know?
And just be free again playing.
You know, I think more
so than anything,
proving that first. And in the midst of
me doing that,
going through the process
of this whole thing.
You know, you building towards
something that we just going have to wait
and see what it pan out
to be at the end of the year.
- When did you realize, "OK,
I am happy again playing basketball."
- Maybe this was my first time
making a decision in my professional life
and my professional career what team I wanna
go to. You know,
I got traded. You know,
really my first time
dealing with free agency
and picking where I wanted to go.
You know, that was kind of a relief,
you know, going into my 13th year saying,
"OK, this is my first time
being able to make a choice."
- Yeah.
- You know, and I made that choice.
And with that, it was kind of
like a burden off my shoulders.
Me just knowing
what I had to do next.
So from there, you know,
I just was at peace with my decision
and just rode it out from there.
- Yeah.
So you said you're,
you've proven to yourself
you can be happy again playing basketball.
When you were unhappy playing basketball,
what does that look like for you?
You don't enjoy the moments.
You don't enjoy the ups
and downs. You know,
you don't enjoy what comes your way.
You don't enjoy, you know,
everything that the game has to bring,
you know, the good, the bad and then the ugly.
You know, you're
not always going to have great days.
So when the great days come,
when the great days aren't there,
you indulge in the negative side of things easier.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
And it kind of makes your days
go by a lot slower,
your week go by a lot slower.
You know, you carry
a lot of stuff with you on your shoulders
when you go out there to perform,
you know, and it just, it
don't feel—
- You feel it all.
- Yeah, you feel it.
You know, you feel it. And I think
that's what being free
feels like now is just
- Yeah.
- enjoying every moment,
even even the long nights, you know, you
enjoy it, because it comes with the job.
You know what I mean? Being banged up,
you enjoy it because it comes
with the competition.
So
- Yeah.
- Just that
part of it for me is, is,
was the transition for me.
It's so funny and interesting
because with a lot of guys,
they talk about how basketball goes from
being this thing
you're good at and that you love to really being—
- Yeah.
- a job.
- And when you're first thinking about it,
like, there's no way I'm going to think
playing basketball in the NBA
is like a job, but you very quickly—
- Yeah.
- Like, ‘Oh, no, this is, this is work.’
And it's going to be
some days that I don’t love this.
Can you explain how you're still doing
something you're very good at,
but there is, like, this other part of it
that weighs you down in some ways?
Yeah, because you know,
you get engulfed in,
you know, the celebrity of being
a professional athlete at times, too, to
where, you know, for me personally, I love,
I love being normal as much as I can.
You know, I love just being normal.
Like whatever that is,
I love being normal.
If it's me walking outside to go
to Starbucks, to get a tea and walk back
like a normal person, you know what I mean, like you,
you love those moments,
but sometimes you realize you can't do it.
And that could kind of,
you know, be a burden on you
sometimes. Like, you know, I'm
just like you, I'm trying to get some tea.
Can I enjoy the tea
like you’re enjoying the tea?
And sometimes you
have those long nights where, you know,
you got to take care of yourself
physically, you know, after a long
week of playing and
you finally get a day off
and you know, you just can't go hang out
with your friends and do certain things
that your friends doing. You got to,
you've got to kind of lock
in. You've got to understand what's next.
You know, it's a consistent thing
that don't stop once you're in a season,
you know. You’re playing every other day
or back-to-back,
or you’re traveling,
or you, you’re in practice, film,
you're taking care of yourself physically.
Then you got to worry
about yourself mentally.
You know, there's so many dynamics
that comes to it,
especially if you want to be good
and successful at it.
You know—
- Yeah.
- it's just not about. ‘I make a lot of money,
I can just go have fun.’
You know, when you’re a pro
and a professional at this,
it’s a lot that comes with it,
you know, and it's tough at times.
So when it comes to being normal,
what do you do for you?
Like, what's the DeMar
thing that makes you feel
normal?
- I mean, watch cartoons, like—
- What cartoon?
I mean, I'm always a Simpsons fan.
I grew up watching
The Simpsons, you know.
Just kid things, you know?
I find myself trying to tap in to
my childhood at times, you know, and just,
you know, try to relive those moments,
whatever they may be.
Sometimes I may get
a coloring book and color
a color, like, a character, you know—
- Yeah.
- just to see if I still got it.
You know, and trying
to find some peace in that, you know.
So it’s just, it's
just, it changes throughout the moments.
But for me, it's just like
you just try to tap in
and just be a kid as much as you can.
Do you stay in the lines?
Yeah, you got to stay in the lines.
You know, you try to—
- No. 1 rule.
- You got to.
Well, hey, luckily for you, you are surrounded
by lots of young people on the Bulls.
How does it feel to be the vet?
- Man, it's crazy cuz
I don’t think I never—
I haven't talked about this yet.
But it's crazy because like whenever music—
like, we listen to music at practice,
and even when we’re in our layup lines in a game,
it'd be certain songs that come on.
And I always ask the guys like,
‘You know who this is?’
They’d be like, "I never heard this song
in my life," and it could be like a Mary J.
Blige song or something, you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
It could be like, it could be a song
from 2005, and they have no clue.
- They’re like, I was just born.
- Yeah.
And it's like, "Well, I was born
in 2001," and it’s like, "Oh, my God." Like,
but at the same time,
you know, it's enjoyable
cuz you learn so much from 'em,
and they teach you so much
in the same token. And once you, like,
accept that, it's fun.
You know, I think one of the guys
one day in practice was like,
"Man, you the only person on the team
born in the '80s.
What it feel like?"
And I'm like, "I'm born in '89.
I'm only 32." Like, you know what I mean?
- [Laughing]
- But it's, it's crazy, you know, to have that back and forth
and we have fun with it.
So it's definitely cool
just to, just to have that
because I learn so much
from those guys as well.
- Yeah. Born in the '80s. It's '89.
- I'm born in—I'm like, yeah.
It's crazy.
- And what music they trying to put you on?
Like NBA YoungBoy or something?
- Everything. You name it, it be some people.
But, but even that, I listen to it.
Like man, who hot right now?
I listen to it just so I can be on the same page
as them as well, you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- So it be cool.
- So when did you realize you were the vet?
Was it when they were like '89?
- Yeah, I think it was like training camp.
It was, it was somewhere around there.
I think we was listening to like,
50 Cent "Get Rich or Die Tryin'" album.
And somebody was like, "Yeah,
I was like one years old, two years old when"—
and I was like, "I remember buying that CD."
You know what I mean?
- That was all anybody cared about. Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah. Like I remember, I told them,
I was like, "Yo, I remember going to the store,
buyin' that. And you just was—"
And that was the moment.
That was my first moment.
I was like, ah yeah,
it's gonna be a long—
it's gonna be a long year.
- Oh yeah, you gotta get them
on all that stuff.
They probably haven't heard
even like, old Wayne—yeah, you have to.
- It's so much—I asked them about Jay-Z.
They was like, "Yeah, I heard about two, three Jay-Z songs."
I'm like…I feel offended.
- For sure.
- You know what I mean? Like, I feel offended!
- Yeah!
Oh no. My gosh, no.
Then you have some teaching to do.
Teaching some real life lessons.
- No, I do. I do. But that's, in their credit,
they, they listen.
- Yeah.
- You know, whatever it is,
not even just music,
just anything in general, even with movies.
Like, I do the same thing with movies.
Have you seen this movie, this movie?
And a lot of them, like it was one guy—
I'mma say his name, Patrick Williams—on the team.
I asked him, I made a reference,
one game we was playing,
I made a reference from "300," the movie "300."
And he didn't get it.
I was like, "You know what '300' is?"
He said, "No."
I said, "It's a movie." He said, "What?"
He said, "Man, I'm gonna go home
and watch it tonight." So he went home,
watched it. Called me after the movie, said,
"Oh my God, that movie was amazing.
You got another movie for me?"
You know what I mean?
- Oh, that's great.
What'd you say, like, "This is Sparta" or something?
- Yeah. It was crazy. It was crazy.
- [Laughing]
- But he went to go watch it and he,
you know?
- That's great. I love that they're,
they're coachable.
- Definitely coachable. Definitely coachable.
- Yeah, they're totally coachable.
So tell me, what makes a good vet?
- Um, something like that.
Just listen.
- Yeah.
- You know, um, you know,
you gotta,
you let guys be guys.
But you teach 'em if they make
any mistakes, you know, show 'em why
or why they shouldn't do something,
you know, and along the way
and kind of be relatable to 'em.
You know what I mean? Every vet
I always had was always relatable,
always talked to me.
They didn't make anything feel forced.
You know, they was, they cared about me
first and foremost,
not just as a player,
just as a person in general,
you know, and I learned so much
from all the vets that I had
my first couple of years in the league,
and I kind of carry that over
to just teaching these guys, you know
what I mean? You really genuinely
wanting the best for them on and off the court.
And I think whatever comes with that
makes a good vet.
- Yeah. Who's been your best vet?
- My best vet?
- Yeah.
- Jarrett Jack was—he was,
he was my favorite vet, you know, to this day.
I talk to J-Jack, you know,
he call me randomly just to talk mess.
But he was, he was one guy
that was definitely instrumental
in my career early on.
- OK, I love this.
On that team, obviously,
you have Alex Caruso, right now
is unfortunately sidelined.
Lonzo Ball sidelined.
When you know, you know,
two guys are going down, two key guys.
- Yeah.
- Where does your mind go?
What do you say to the team
to make sure you guys are still locked in?
- Um, just keep the confidence high.
Understand it's an opportunity
that someone else may not had
if these guys were healthy
to be able to have a chance to,
you know, fill in that role, you know,
and that's what a team is made of,
guys understanding when, when one key guy
go down, what can you do to benefit
and help and fill that void to continue
to keep us successful?
And it's a chance to learn and to grow,
you know, and approach that position
with nothing but confidence.
So for me, that's all I do,
and I tell guys, just be confident,
you know what I mean? Don't overthink it,
don't feel pressured.
You know, we all in this together.
So that's one thing I definitely share.
- I just really love this
like evolution of your career
that has happened
and the path that it has gone on, because
would you say it's accurate to say
this has been like, I mean, based on the normal,
like a late-career surge? Would you call it that?
- Yeah, yeah, for sure.
- So, is this how you envisioned
your NBA career going?
- For me, I always envision anything I do,
I want to continue to get better at it.
You know, whatever
that look like, I want to
continue to get better at it,
and whatever opportunity I can have
in getting better at it, I'm gonna
try to fill that
to my highest potential.
- Yeah.
- You know? And that's the challenge
I take on every single year.
I never look at, you know, years
as being a down year.
You kind of look at years as a growing
year. You know, you planted whatever seed.
Sometimes it takes time
for you to grow and fully understand
what was planted, you know?
And I think as long
as you keep planting seeds and
allowing them to grow and be patient,
you know, you're going to continue
to stay consistent
in whatever you're doing. If that's gardening,
if it's farming, whatever it is,
you know, as long as you continue to do it
and you continue to see your process.
- OK, that final year with San Antonio,
what seed did you plant?
- Um...Damn, I wish I knew some...I planted
probably a cornfield.
You know?
- Why a cornfield?
- I don't know, because you just sound
like a lot will grow
and you could feed a lot of people with it.
- Yeah.
- No, it was...It was one of those seeds of,
you know, I've got to
give credit to all the guys
I played with in San Antonio.
Even a lot of young guys that, you know,
they motivated me and pushed me, um,
in a sense of having so much respect
for me and my game and allowing me to be them.
And helping them
to the best of their abilities.
And it created like
a bond of me understanding
basketball from a full perspective
and not just yourself.
You know, I stopped
caring about myself, so to speak.
You know, it was moreso a team aspect
when I looked at all
the guys I played with in San Antonio,
you know, and it opened,
it made me more open-minded
of having a higher IQ, approaching
the game from a whole perspective
and not feeling like, you know,
I'm Superman. I need to go out there
and do it all by yourself.
So, that definitely was a career lesson
for me that I learned from
every single player.
Even playing for Pop.
You know, that was one thing that
he helped me unlock mentally from my game.
- I would say that,
you know, most players in the league,
they just want respect from their peers.
- Most definitely.
- When do you feel like you got that respect
and that kind of vindication
within the league?
- Um...that's crazy
you say that, because that's all I ever...
that's all I ever wanted. That was...
It wasn't about how much money you made.
None of that. Like,
I didn't want to go outside.
I didn't want to go party.
I didn't want to hang out.
I didn't want to go on vacations 'til
I felt accepted by my peers. And I think
probably my fourth year in league,
fourth, fifth year in the league,
think I made my first All-Star Game, too.
And you know, you just felt like you
belonged, and you was accepted by your peers.
Your peers respected you
when you stepped out there on the court,
you know. And that's the highest
compliment you could have in
this league is when your peers respect
you, your game inside and out,
and you as a, you as a person.
You know, that goes a long way
to adding respect in this league.
So, I'd say my fourth, fifth year.
- So do you still continue
to seek that validation,
or do you think you're comfortable
with the things that you've accomplished?
- Nah, I'm not comfortable at all.
I don't think I will ever be comfortable
until, you know,
I decide to walk away from it, you know.
And I think that's the beauty of playing
this game is to give everything
for as long as you can to it
so by the time you walk away, you
you could walk away feeling
at ease with walking away, you know?
And that's one thing I want to,
you know, knock on wood,
have the opportunity to be able to do
is to walk away from the game
at peace, you know.
And that was one thing, you know,
Coach always used to talk to me about,
you know, that's when you know.
When you know
you can walk away at ease from the game,
when you have peace.
- Yeah. And what do you think
that peace looks like?
- I dunno. You just keep striving.
You know, you just give
everything you got into this game.
until you feel like
you can't give no more.
Then you look back at everything you did
and you may realize
like, "Damn, I did a lot of things."
- Yeah.
- You know, and evaluate it,
it's what you comfortable with at that point.
- Mm-hmm.
Sometimes when guys talk about,
you know, when they realize
they have the respect of their peers
and they felt vindicated,
they can remember like a specific guy
saying something to them, and they said,
"Oh, when he knew I was nice."
- Wow.
- "I knew I was nice."
- That's a...
- Is someone like that for you?
- Yeah. And it's crazy. It's crazy. That's...
One person who
my rookie year told me something
that stuck with me.
I don't even know if he remember
this, is Michael Redd.
He told me I was gonna be special
in this league. Keep, keep,
don't stop. Like,
I just remember those words so vividly.
"You gonna be special in this league.
Don't stop. Keep working." It was my rookie year,
Michael Redd. I never got
the chance to tell him
thank you for that.
He might, he may not even remember.
- Yeah.
- But Michael Redd told me those words,
and it stuck with me to this day.
- Really?
Why do you think in that moment, like, that
was so, it resonated so deeply for you?
- I don't know. At that time, you know,
he was a veteran.
You know, he was an established player.
He was a player, like, I've always been
a fan of the game of basketball.
'70s, '80s, '90s.
So I always respected
all the older guys.
- Mmhmm.
- Honest.
I respected what Michael Redd did
in the league.
And I don't know.
It's just that moment where he pulled me
to the side and, you know,
I felt how genuine he was about it,
you know what I mean? Because even at that point,
my rookie year, you know,
you deal with so many emotions
questioning, like, damn, "When am I gonna be good?
When Imma be able to be myself?
When am I gonna be comfortable?" Like, I'm
only 19 years old playing with grown men.
So for him to pull me to the side
and acknowledge something
towards me that I was feeling
iffy about was all I needed.
- Shoutout Michael Redd.
- I love that.
OK.
-  I never told nobody that either.
I never told nobody.
- Look at us!
- It's crazy.
- We do this.
- Yeah, you got it.
- You know, we get the stories.
So, all right, looking at your career.
Haven't been to the NBA Finals.
- Mmhmm.
- How often do you think about that?
- All the time. All the time. You know,
the older you get, the more years that pass,
you watch Finals after Finals,
and, you know, you come into your first game
of the season, you strive
to want to make the Finals.
You know, you want to be
the last team playing.
You know, that's your motivation.
If you're a true competitor in this game,
you wanna go to the Finals.
You wanna know what that feel like.
You want to have a chance to compete for
the trophy, you know, so
it always played on my mind,
you know, and I always watch it.
You know, you always find inspiration,
motivation and just want to get there
and see what happens, you know.
So it's something I always think about.
- So when you're thinking about the NBA
Finals or not going, what's
running through your mind?
Is it ever a moment of, like, OK, like,
I need to get there;
the time is now?
What's the emotion?
- I mean, just stay the course.
You know, I think, I
look at things day by day.
You know, you work towards
something day by day.
You can't look at it,
you know, a week from now,
a month from now. It's like, all right,
what can I do today to be my best today
and do the same tomorrow and tomorrow?
And hopefully, by the time
you get to that final day,
you look up and you're in the Finals. You
know, and that's how I approach it
because you don't want to
drive yourself too crazy.
- Yeah.
- Like, I need to make the Finals.
I need to make the Finals.
And sometimes they don't
necessarily go that way.
So for me, it's just, you know,
taking it day by day.
- Yeah. And I really do
think sometimes people underestimate
just how difficult that road
to the Finals is.
- Yeah.
- Like, winning a championship is no tiny feat.
And winning games is, like, only some of it.
- Yeah.
- You know, there's so much other work
- So much, yeah.
- that really goes into that.
What are your thoughts on ring culture?
Do you think that we put
too much emphasis on a player's,
like, worth based on their championships
or their rings?
- I think so.
You know, I'd always
go back and look at,
you know, you can look at all the great,
there's so many great players
that don't have rings.
And if you bring up that player versus
another player who do have a ring,
you will discredit that great player by saying he don't have a ring.
- Right.
- But that don't,
you can't take away from all
the accomplishments he had in his career
because some people don't even
get half of what some of these
great players have to
because they don't have a ring.
You want to, you know, say he not like
this player because he have a ring.
So,
- Mmhmm.
- you know, at times I do feel like,
you know, it's a lot thrown on it.
You know, because you ask
all those competitors, they wish
they had a ring.
- Yeah.
- You know, that's the ultimate thing for us all to have.
- Mmhmm.
- But you know, everybody can't have a ring.
But that don't mean you can't work
your butt off and be the best teammate,
best player you can be throughout
your whole career.
- Mmhmm.
That was one of the things I loved about,
you know, the Finals last season.
It's, like, I wanted to see someone
get their first ring.
- For sure.
- Like, I either wanted to see Chris
Paul and Devin Booker get it.
Wanted to see Giannis get it. It was exciting
cuz it was someone was going
to finally accomplish this thing
that it's all we talk about.
- Yep.
- So it was really cool to watch that.
You certainly are a great player.
I wanna throw this out to you,
which I'm sure you know.
But, you know, against the Magic,
You had a season-high 41 points,
but you did it
without taking a single three-pointer.
Are you, like, the mid-range king?
- I mean, I…
- [Laughing]
- People crowned me that. They say it.
I see it. It's an honor.
I appreciate it.
- Yeah.
- I just stay true to myself.
You know, I try to master
whatever it is I do on that court
to the best of my abilities
and go out there feel like,
you know, I'm the best at whatever I do
when I step out there on that court.
You know, you would never hear me say
I'm the mid-range king and all this
cuz, you know,
I learned so much from a lot of those—
I talk to CP all the time
about how he get, you know,
to the mid-range and, you know, how
he take advantage of so many things.
You know, I watch all the great players.
I watch Kawhi. I watch KD. I watch,
I learned so much
from all these players that helped me
be the player, you know, that I am today.
So it's hard for me to just say I'm
the best or I'm the greatest at something,
you know what I mean?
But…
- Yeah.
- I feel like when I go out there, you know,
I work my butt off to be great at what I do.
- Yes, and—but
you know you're very good at it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- OK. People do call that mid-range shot,
like, a lost art.
- Yeah.
- Why do you think they refer to it that way?
- Because you don't see too many people
doing it at that level.
Myself may do it. CP may do
it. Devin Booker may do it.
KD may do it. Kawhi may do it.
You know, it's a select
few guys who dominate the mid-range,
and in the same token, you
look around the league,
you get so many other players
that, you know, launch
threes so much, you know?
So, you know, it's just a narrative that's painted out there
because, you know, it's still a necessity of the game.
The mid-range shot is still a necessity
and a need in the game.
- Mmhmm.
- But you know, we emphasize three-point
shooting so much.
And it's hard not to when you have, you know,
Steph Curry, Klay Thompson. You have,
you know, Trae Young.
You have so many players
that do that at a high level as well.
But, you know, I think the guys that's
keeping it mid-range
is definitely balancing
it back out.
- Yeah.
But because it feels like there
is this major push for teams to
just be so heavy on the three,
- Yeah.
- was there a moment for you,
you thought, do I need to adapt to this?
- No. I just always, what—
It's another thing Kobe told me.
He just always told me,
stay true to myself.
You know, I remember he tell me that way
back in
2015. Just to stay true to yourself,
you know, stay the course.
No matter what somebody may say,
you keep working at your craft,
you become unstoppable at something.
Until I figure that out,
be true to yourself.
And those words stuck with me to this day,
you know, so I never wanted to give in
into just coming down, you know,
shooting threes, threes, threes, threes
when I know I could get to a certain spot
that I know is unguardable.
Until that is stopped, Imma continue to do it.
- Yeah. It's not broke,
don't fix it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. OK,
a lot of season left,
but are you the MVP?
- Me the MVP?
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah, I came in this season thinking
I was the MVP.
- OK.
- You know, and that's
just my mentality, you know,
not in a selfish manner,
but just knowing the work that I put in.
And not just for myself as well. For,
you know, my team. You know, my team
has overcome so much so
quick, you know,
and it sucks that we are dealing
with so many injuries of late, but
that's—the team we had pushed me
and allowed me to be the player I knew
I was, you know, and that showed.
You know, my own mentality
coming into this season
felt like I was the best player,
you know, dealing with so much doubt and
so much criticism.
For whatever reason, you know,
I had that mentality coming in, saying,
Imma be the best me.
And whatever comes with that, whether
if it's MVP, king of the mid-range,
whatever. I was gonna take it.
- Yeah.
What is the MVP to you? Cuz it, you know, it feels like
people have different criteria.
- Yeah.
- For you, what is it?
- To me, the MVP is
establishing a winning culture for one.
For not just your teammates, for your organization.
Being the ultimate leader.
Dealing with adversity like it's
a sunny day in the middle of Chicago.
You know, just, it's so many responsibilities
that come with that.
And the ones that carry it on
on their shoulders like it's a feather.
That's the MVP, you know,
night in and night out doing your job.
Being banged up, being hurt,
still taking on that challenge to push
and make your team successful.
Being, you know, short-handed. Still
coming to work, perform or doing whatever
you need to do to carry your team.
To me, that's the MVP, you know,
and we have so many of them in our league
that do it, you know. Someone
I love watching every single night.
Chris Paul, you know. Chris Paul
don't go out there and score
30, 40 points a night.
But the way he carries
his team is the ultimate true MVP,
you know, and he's been carrying himself
like an MVP every single year.
Every team he go to
taking that winning culture, taking
that leadership, taking that,
that next step in,
you know, pushing his teammates
and making everybody around him better.
To me, that's an MVP. Yeah.
- So what does MVP signify for you?
Like, if you win MVP this season,
what does it prove
to yourself as a player?
Prove to others as a player?
Um, it's never doubt,
never give up on yourself.
Never feed into the negativity, the doubt.
Um, when you truly believe in yourself
and you work towards something
with everything in you, and you
believe in timing and patience.
That's an MVP for me.
You know, just being that inspiration of
of, you know, you could be counted out
by the masses of people.
But as long as you believe in yourself,
that's all that matters
and you will forever be an MVP.
Whether someone give you a trophy or not,
you know? So to me, it is something
that you carry internally
because, you know, without your,
your confidence in everything you believe
in, you let other people take away
because of word of mouth, then you know
you're not going to be the MVP.
- Yeah, I'm ready to run through a wall.
Question, though, because a word
that keeps being said a lot is "doubt."
Very clear. You felt like people
really were doubting you before you
made this move here to Chicago.
Why do you think people doubted you?
- I don't know. I wish, I wish…
I wish with the doubt
they explained the doubt,
because I didn't understand it.
You know, and I think for me
and I always try to be a motivation
and inspiration for people who always feel
doubted in whatever field it is.
You know what I mean?
People don't realize,
like, the way I grew up,
I grew up in Compton, California,
all you heard was doubt and negativity.
You know, and I seen
so many people give in to it
so easy, and I always took offense
to that my whole life. You know,
so it was always like a trigger for me,
that's bigger than just basketball.
You know, like, I had to fight
against the doubt with so many things.
So many things in life.
And it was it was always on me to be like,
"Nah, damn that doubt.
You say I can't do it? Watch.
I'mma do it just because of that.
- Yeah.
You know what I mean? And I carry
that same mentality to this day.
And I always tell people,
like, when you hear a naysayer, anybody,
any walk of life, don't
one second feed into that,
because you lose as soon as
you think that way.
You know, and for me, when I hear that
I'm gonna take on a challenge
as best as I can every single
way. It pisses me off
because who are you
to speak on me with anything?
You know what I mean?
- Mmhmm
- Like, I just, you know, I hate it.
- Yeah. Can you give me an example?
You said, "I've been
fighting doubt for my whole life."
- Um, I mean, I remember
dealing with people.
I remember growing up, you hear
people across the street
saying—it could be a group of kids,
when I was a kid, it was a group of us
running around saying,
"None of ya'll ain't gonna be nothing
anyway, ya'll need to take your ass in the house."
You know I was like, "What you mean
I ain't gonna be nothing?"
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean? It's like.
Just because of that, I'mma show
you I'mma  be something,
you know what I mean? And sometimes
that's all the motivation you need
growing up where I grew up at,
you know what I mean?
But you heard it so consistently.
You know, I heard teachers
tell students saying,
"You ain't gonna be nothing.
You ain't even gonna graduate."
What? Like, you know what I mean?
- That's wild.
- Like, you know what I mean? So when
you hear those things, you
take it personally, you know,
and sometimes that's the push you need.
But when you consistently
hear it over and over, it's like, "No,
all right, I'mma take on this challenge."
- Yeah, it's funny how life works, though,
because when you think about that,
there's probably a really good case to be
made that if you never heard any of that,
your life could've turned out differently.
- For sure.
No question.
- You know?
- No question.
No question. So is it works
different for everybody,
you know what I mean? For me, like,
you know, I needed it.
You know, that was my push.
You know, it's like, "You said,
I can't do something?
Well, all right, I'm 'bout to try, and
I'mma keep trying until I get good at it."
- Mmhmm.
- And next thing you know, I'm good at it.
Now what? Then they find something else.
Now what? You know,
you just keep meeting it.
That's that was my positive
approach to negativity.
- Yeah, I mean, and that's
probably the best way to do it,
because there's always gonna
be negativity around you.
- For sure.
- It's more so just how are
you going to channel this
to better yourself and better your career
and what you're doing?
- Yup.
- So I love that. I have two reports
I wanna ask you about,
- Mmhmm.
- you tell me if they were true.
- Talk to me.
- You were gonna take a pay
cut to join the Lakers.
- I never understood what
was a pay cut, though.
- Cuz anything really technically could've been—
- Yeah, anything—I could've took a dollar less.
That's a pay cut.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- But for the sake of the report—
- Yeah.
- Were you going to take a substantial pay
cut to be able to play for the Lakers?
- Substantial? I wouldn't say substantial.
- But a hefty—
- A pay cut.
- A cut.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- OK.
- It was a, it was a—
it was an option.
- Yeah.
- It was, it was a, it
was a real realistic option.
- OK. And obviously things worked out the way they were supposed to.
- Yeah, it worked out.
- You're with the Bulls, and you're great.
But explain to me why you say
it was an option and just—
- One, I wanted to go home.
That was an opportunity for me to go home.
You know, you don't get that
opportunity often.
You know, I got it
before, but I decided to stay in Toronto.
It was an option, you know?
Have a, have
the opportunity to play with
one of the greatest players of all time.
So why not? It's hard
to turn that down, you know?
And the want to compete for a championship
in your hometown.
Like, all those elements just had lined up
to allow me to consider
a realistic pay cut.
- [Laughing] OK, so realistic pay cut.
- Yeah.
- OK, fair. Makes sense.
Another talk—or, another report
I remember seeing, that you and Kyle
may be talking about teaming up.
I don't know how—
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is this true?
- That's true. We talked about it.
- OK. Walk me through it.
- No, we had talked about teaming up.
What was our options?
How realistic could certain options be?
What made sense for him,
what made sense for me.
And nothing just ultimately aligned
in the right way
where it could have benefited both of us
in a way, you know, we both needed.
We wanted it too for us to play together,
but it definitely was a talk.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, were you close? It just—
- Ah, I wouldn't say it was close,
but it was talked about.
- OK.
- It was talked about.
- How is Kyle?
- He's good. He's good.
- Kyle's so funny.
You're—y'all's friendship
is so interesting to me because, and
I mean this with so much respect
and love in my heart,
Kyle really is an asshole.
- No, for sure.
- Like, so—when you know him, he's so nice.
- Yeah, I've been on record saying it.
- Yeah. He's great.
He has always been very kind to me,
but he is an asshole to people who
maybe don't know him. So
did you always like Kyle?
- No.
- OK.
- No, and he know it,
and everybody around
know it. Our first year together—
because anybody that know me,
I'm such a, I'm a chill person,
stay to myself.
But I do have a certain side to me
that I just never wanna bring out.
And Kyle was an asshole to where
I knew if I was around him long enough,
he would bring that other side out.
So I just stayed away from him
cuz I didn't know him.
I didn't know him personally
to understand him.
But as time went on,
and we just ended up in certain situations
together in the game, off the court,
you know, you start to learn them,
understand them more.
It was like, "Yo, this is my dawg."
Like, I'll run through 10 brick
walls for him in a heartbeat—
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean? And it's
just crazy how it worked.
You know, when they say opposites attract,
that's, you know, that's,
you know, ultimately what happened.
But he's definitely an asshole.
But in that same token, he's one of the
best people to have as a friend.
- Totally.
- No question. Like I, no matter what
I can call him any time of the night.
If I needed $5 million, he'd, "OK,
I'll send it in the morning,"
you know what I mean?
- Totally.
- Just—not saying I'd ask him for that, but I'm
just saying, that's just what
type of friend he is when he really care
and love for somebody, you know what I mean?
He would give his last
just to make sure you straight, so.
- Yeah.
- You know, on top of him being an asshole,
he's one of the best friends you'll have.
- Yes, he's a great human.
And it's interesting
because you all—a lot of guys in the league,
you know, they're like, "Oh, this is my dude.
This is my best friend." Y'all are really
best friends for life forever.
- Yeah, that's my dawg.
- Yeah. And I don't think
we see that all the time.
- Nah, because this—
and it's crazy because, like,
nobody really see us outside of,
you know, basketball.
But, like, everything we do
outside of basketball
is the most normal stuff in the world.
We will argue over
the most craziest situation
that ain't got nothin' to do with sports.
Like, you know, that's really
real life my friend.
Like, once—I'm pretty sure
when we 50, 60 years old,
we're gonna be sitting on the porch
telling stories.
And I'mma be saying
he lied about something and vice versa.
You know what I mean? Like,
that's us. That's gonna be us.
- Yeah.
No, I love a beautiful friendship,
so that's amazing.
I hope you guys get to see
each other in the offseason and stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, we do.
- OK.
- But, like you said,
people don't get to see that side.
They see when we play against each other.
But whenever he come to L.A.,
we spend a lot of time together
when people don't see.
- Yeah, no, I see that. I love that.
Y'all are everybody's favorite
NBA friendship. Totally.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I definitely want to make sure
that I give you my love
and my condolences about your dad, Frank,
who unfortunately passed.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I read how you call him Big Dog,
and I love that nickname.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Tell me why you call him that.
- Um...it really started from my cousin,
my other cousin that's here,
just always called him Big Dog.
Like, he was always the Big Dog.
My dad was the boss
of all bosses.
Like, when I got to the league, he always
said like, "I'm still the boss.
I don't care how much money you've got."
So it was always like, "All right.
My bad, Big Dog. You got it." You know?
And he just always carried himself in
being a protector
of the whole family, you know? And that's
where the term Big Dog comes from. Of him
just, you know, kind of
just always being the enforcer,
you know, in the most positive
and loving way, as much as he could.
And, you know, everybody loved my dad.
So, you know, that's
kind of where it stemmed from.
But I've gotta give that credit to my,
my older cousin.
He gave him that nickname
and we all just stuck with it.
- That's great.
What parts of your dad
do you see in you?
- Um...relentless.
I done seen him go through
everything, you know, and not
not break, not fold,
not give up, not complain.
And that's one trait, to this day,
you know, even after he passed that,
I revealed...that I realized that
I had that much in me from him,
you know? And it was
it was crazy because it was like,
you know, even when he passed,
it's like, it's all right.
Everything you taught me
for these 31 years
helped me through this,
through this tragedy.
You know what I mean?
- Mm-hmm.
- And I felt that learning everything
that I went through with my dad
watching him, everything he taught me
just everything, you know,
and I realize that more than
- Yeah.
anything after I lost him.
- Like in some ways, his life prepared you for his death.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, I mean, it's crazy that you
say that
because that's exactly what it was.
- Yeah. I read you saying that you felt
you hadn't dealt with it personally yet.
Like, you didn't really get that moment to grieve yet.
- Mm-hmm.
- But when it comes, you were gonna let it hit you.
- Yeah.
- Have you been able to deal with it?
- Nah, I still haven't.
And it's the most eerie thing for me, because um,
like, you know, I don't know when it's gonna come,
how it's gonna come.
You know, it's just...
I got him tatted on my arm
because I feel like I carry him
everywhere I go, you know, and it's
one of those things to where
it's like, I'm just waiting for him
to pop off my arm and tell me something.
You know what I mean? For me
to just like, let it all out, you know?
But it's something that maybe it's just
the strength that I've gotten from him
allow me to just keep pushing.
But at some point, I know
it'll get to me whenever
it need to get to me
in the right time.
- Yeah, my mom,
when she was younger, her brother passed
and then both of her parents passed
within a year-and-a-half of each other.
And one thing that she has taught me
a lot about grief
is she's like, "Grief really
isn't a thing that goes away."
She's like, "When people
haven't dealt with big losses,
they feel like, you know, through time
it feels better," you know?
She's like, "It's more that
like, through time, it feels more real.
And you become accustomed
to living in that, that realness of it."
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Have you learned that about grief?
- For sure.
I learned, and it sucks,
because just like what you said,
I've learned it so early on,
you know, that, you know, not necessarily
it made me numb to it,
it just made me understand
the value of life
when you say you love
somebody. You know, um,
I've lost countless uncles
at a young age to gun violence.
I lost, at 16, lost my grandmother.
Six days later, I lost my grandfather.
You know, so from that same token
what you just said, you learn how to
deal with it in the moment
because it never, it never goes away.
You know, you have your good,
your bad days. But you learn,
you learn to deal with and you learn,
at the same token,
to appreciate your loved ones even more.
You know? There's two things that
I've kind of learned throughout my whole life.
That's why I always give so much respect to people
when I come across people,
you know what I mean? It's like, I'm always be—
- Yeah. Mm-hmm.
- Giving you the utmost respect
because I want you to feel my energy.
You know what I mean? Because nothing
is never promised, you know?
- 100 percent. Yeah.
- I lost so much before
I could even understand
what death was, you know what I mean?
So that's something I always carry
when I'm always meeting
people or I'm always around people is,
you know, you try to give off that lasting
impression because I would hope me
being the way I am will help you
be like that to somebody else.
- Yeah.
- And so that's just always been my mentality.
- That's good. And honestly, that was what
I thought about when I saw the news.
Cuz, you remember, we did, like, last summer…
yeah, like, last summer—
we talked about—kind of during George
Floyd, we did that interview.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
- And one thing you discussed
was feeling very desensitized to death—
- Yeah.
- In a lot of ways.
How it has—like, you were always
going to funerals
when you were younger,
and it just kind of started to be
something that felt like very much
so a part of your life.
So I'm really glad to hear that
you are, you know,
coping really well with it—
- Yeah.
- Day to day and pushing through.
And I know you said you really were
looking for kind of this peace with it.
When do you feel like
you'll find that peace?
Have you come close?
- Um, I'm not sure.
I really wish I had an answer to give.
Not just for myself. Just for anybody
who dealin' with any type of tragedy.
And I just—for me,
I just realize, like, life is
one of those things you realize
you just will never have the full answer to,
you know? You just gotta deal with it
in real time with real emotions,
you know? And I don't run from 'em,
you know? For a lotta my years,
when I was young, I ran from a lotta,
a lotta my tragedies because I felt like,
well, I was just running from it
cuz I don't wanna be next, you know?
- Mmhmm.
- And that's, you know,
especially for me, losing so many friends
so, so early, it was like,
you know, I didn't wanna deal with it
because I just didn't wanna
deal with it, you know? It's like—
- Yeah.
- Cuz I always felt like it never was gonna stop.
- Mmhmm.
- But, you know, it's
just one of those things like,
you know, you gotta deal with it.
Like, we human at the end of the day.
- Yeah.
- We got emotions.
You gotta feel 'em, you know?
And that's what, that's what makes you
you is when you, you know, you indulge
in emotion. Because there's nothing realer than
emotion, you know? You can't see it, but
you feel it more than anything, you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Whether if it's happy, sad, you gotta feel it.
You gotta feel it. And for me,
when I do feel those things, I
indulge in it because that's
the only thing that makes me feel human.
- Yeah. It's like you have to feel it,
and you have to be able to talk about it
too. Even just when I think about the, like,
the expectations
that society and culture puts on people,
but men specifically—
- Yeah.
- Like, feeling like they cannot say
if they're sad or hurt or need help.
- Yeah.
- And that's one of the things
everybody says they give you a big credit
for just really talking about
how you felt. And I know we discussed this
last time, that Kevin Love saying
you are the entire reason
he felt like he could do that, too.
- Yeah.
- Do you see, like, what you kind of
are to people cuz you're so open?
- Yeah, but I look towards people…
rather they know it—
I look towards other people's stories
more than anything,
because that's what keeps me going.
You know what I mean?
Like, people may look at me
like, "Oh, you did—"
But a lotta times, even players,
I don't know, even in sports
I don't know, not even in
sports, in the entertainment world.
Anyone who has a story for me,
I indulge in because
I gain so much empathy
and inspiration from that because
we carry so much that people don't see,
you know what I mean? Like, I
always look at people on TV and be like,
"I wonder how they do this,"
whether if it's a comedian or something.
Like, "How'd you do this? Because you have a life
outside of this."
You know what I mean?
- Mmhmm.
- Like, what's your story?
So when I can find stories—
like Jim Carrey, for
one. That's one person I
always—if he do an interview,
If he speak so much stuff, I indulge
in him because his—the way he speaks on
humanity and being
human and empathy, depression
and so much stuff,
he paints a picture with it.
You know what I mean?
It's the most incredible thing,
and I find so much inspiration in it
because he realized something
through everything he been through.
And he speaks on it.
You know what I mean?
- Mmhmm.
- And to me, that's amazing
when anybody, any walk of life, does that.
And I find inspiration and motivation
to keep going with that
because we all got a story.
- Yeah.
- We all got a story. So it's just crazy.
But when—if anybody look at me
that way, I hope I help
in any type of way
when I, whenever I speak out,
I'm still trying to learn
to get my words out the best I can
to express my emotions and my feelings
whenever I'm going through something
the best way I can to help people out.
But, you know, I lean on everything
and everybody as much as I can,
whether people know it or not.
- No, that's great.
And you really are a testament
to, like, people don't really know
the full scope of anybody.
Cuz I actually didn't know
until I was prepping for this that that
season you were flying to see your dad.
- Yeah. I don't think I never—
I never talked about it. For three—
even in Toronto.
My dad got sick Christmas 2018.
My last year in Toronto,
my dad got sick, went in the hospital.
I flew home a couple days
before Christmas,
sat with my dad. And he was, he was in the hospital
for the next—in and out of the hospital
the next three years after that.
So in three years,
I was—I done flew from Boston
to L.A., L.A. to Toronto
by myself, played in the game.
Did the same thing in San Antonio.
But nobody
never knew. It was times I flew in
day of the game and played,
from seeing my dad.
- So, leave L.A.,
fly in game day and play that night.
- Play that night.
I did it so many times, countless times.
I never talked about it.
Never talked about it.
- I mean, how difficult was that
when you were making these trips
and then having to go to work?
- I mean,
it was, it was, it was the most—
it was probably the hardest thing
in my life to do because, you know,
you have so much idle
time of sitting on a plane by yourself,
dealing with the emotional,
like, trauma of seeing your dad—
seeing the person, that only person in life
I ever feared,
you know, down and out,
to having to go play
in front of 20,000 people.
You know, it was like
the emotional roller coaster
that I dealt with for,
you know, three years was
one of the toughest things ever
because, one. I never wanted to be
a distraction to my teammates,
to the game or nothing.
So, you know, I dealt with everything
I dealt with personally,
and I didn't wanna be loud about it.
I didn't want nobody necessarily
to feel sorry for me and everything, but
I also wanted to be there for my teammates
and my family, you know what I mean?
So to carry those emotions consistently,
you know, behind the scenes,
and nobody knew, you know, it was, it was,
it was tough. It was tough.
Like, even when I lost my dad,
I was in a hotel in Charlotte.
Like, just finished playing a game. Fly home,
you know, home a couple of days,
and I flew back with the team, played
in a game. Fly back home, go to his funeral
leave for shootaround and go play.
You know, it was like
all those emotions to where—
what really made it
hard, you know, like I said,
I'm sitting on a plane
by myself for hours, like,
you know, with this
on your mind, trying to figure out how,
all right, how you gonna balance yourself
out to be able to play tonight,
you know?
- Yeah.
- But I needed to play. Like I said, my teammates, guys
I played with knew what I was going through,
and they was always there for me,
and they made it easy for me.
And that's why I always felt like I had
to be there for them as well to compete.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, that was for three years.
- Yeah, because I mean, on a plane,
like, literally all you can do is think.
- Yeah.
- Like, you're just in your head.
- In your head the whole time.
- The entire time.
- And I would assume
when you were playing basketball,
you were also thinking
about everything too.
- For me, basketball was my escape.
It's always been my escape from everything.
Like my whole entire life,
that was always my thing. Like,
I needed to go play basketball, but it was,
it was hard because, you know, those two
hours, those two-and-a-half hours you
in between those lines, you feel free.
Soon as you walk outside those lines, it's
like, "All right, I'm out the matrix now.
So, like, how am I to deal
with what's next?"
- Yeah.
- You know, and it's back to it.
This, for a prime example,
never told anybody this.
Like, this is why Kyle's
one of my— will forever be my man.
It was, it was so many games we played in to
where his locker was next to mine,
where we'd—when we'd come out
the game and sit next
to each other in the locker room,
he used to say, he was like,
"Man, back to reality
now. Do you—what can I—you know I'm here with you."
You know what I mean?
Because he knew the severity
and understood what I was going through
more than anybody. So,
yeah, that's what I was dealing with.
- Wow.
Oh, my gosh. I am so sorry to hear that.
But I do wanna give you an opportunity:
Tell us, what should we know about your dad?
What did you love the most about your dad?
- What I loved—everything
I loved about him was everything
as a kid, you hated about him, you know
what I mean?
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- He'd push you so hard to where it was like,
"Man, I don't wanna play basketball anymore.
I don't wanna do this.
I just wanna go home.
I wanna watch cartoons."
But he instilled so much in me
that made me the person and the man
that I am today. My discipline,
my awareness to
just life in general. How to read
and be kind to people.
How to, you know, be the survival—
like, how to survive
in the toughest environment. Like, everything.
And besides all that, just being a loving
dad. You know what I mean? He loved—
he gave me tough love, but he loved,
he loved the hell out of me every bit, so.
- Yeah.
- He was just one of those dudes
that everybody loved. Like, everybody.
- Yeah. Oh, that's so beautiful.
How old are your kids now?
- My kids, my oldest
about to be nine.
- Wow.
- It's, it's—
- [Laughing] That's wild.
- See, that's when it start making me feel
old, when you start asking—that's
what really makes me feel old.
- "Yeah, I got a nine-year-old." Yeah.
- Like [exhaling]—
it's drivin' me crazy when I sit over
here and think about it.
- I love it. Well, you know what
I think of now when I think of,
like. a kid, I think of Steven
Adams picking up—
- Oh, yeah. Oh, my teammate?
- Yes!
- Yeah, I told him—
- Picking him up!
- Yeah, I told him. I said, "Tony, you too big
to let a grown man pick you up. Your feet
dangling off the ground."
- [Laughing] It was so bad.
- Yeah.
- Like, literally Steven Adams picked him up,
like your one-year-old and said,
"All right, get off of my, of my teammate."
There's no way Tony got back to his—
he had to look at his phone and say,
"I ain't even gonna look at this tonight,
cuz they killin' me online."
- Yeah, yeah, they was—
I was killin' him
in the locker room. Trust me.
- Oh my gosh, I love it.
Well, it is always so amazing to see you,
but I do have one more question for you.
We're having some fans in the app
ask questions, which I'm
happy about because you know Ayo went to
University of Illinois,
my alma mater, I-L-L,
You know, big fan of Ayo.
I saw it before the Bulls saw it, you know?
- Yeah. You did, yeah.
- What's it like
being a mentor to him?
- Man, I love it, man. He a hell of a kid, man.
And I don't even like callin' kids
"kids" cuz, at the end of the day, you a man, aren't you?
But he, he's special.
- Mmhmm.
- He's special. Not just basketball-wise.
That's been showing for itself with
what he do on the court,
but off the court, man, he a
hell of a dude. And he's special.
He one of a kind.
He one of the most inquisitive young kids
that I've ever been around.
Like, if I tell him somethin',
he will ask 10 questions
about that one subject.
- Really?
- But what—but, you know that—
and he sincerely wanna know and learn,
you know what I mean?
Like, he'll sit up here
and ask me about certain players
from 10 years ago. "How was he?"
So, and stuff like that
just let me know how special he is.
So it's dope. It's dope to be able to
be any type of mentor towards him in
any type of way.
- And did you enjoy your time at University of Illinois?
- I had a great time. Yeah, I had—
- It's a great campus, right?
- A great campus, yes.
- Yes.
- And I was, I was—
it was far. But, yeah,
It was, it was worth it.
But just being there, supporting him,
just getting a college atmosphere, just,
you know, seeing what that was like,
it was dope.
- Yeah, cuz you were there—
it was for his jersey retirement, correct?
- Yeah, for his retirement.
- Which totally, like, speaks to you going to
Champaign to be there for your teammate.
Such a good vet!
- Nah, yeah, I had to go.
I had to text him.
I had actually texted him
mad that he didn't tell me.
- Ohh!
- I'm like, "Damn, you can't tell me
about your jersey retirement?"
He said, "My bad, big brah." I said, "I'll be there."
He was like, "What, for real?!"
I said, "Yeah, I'll be there." And
I ended up going.
- Oh, my gosh. Yeah, like, my Illinois
group chats, they're sending photos, you know,
I'm like, "Wow, DeMar is at State Farm Center."
I love that. What a guy!
- Yeah, I had to.
- Didn't—the Lakers missed out, didn't they?
- Did they?
- Did they?! Hey,
looks like it. No, you are phenomenal.
I am so appreciative of you.
You come on the show whenever I say, "Hey,
do you wanna come on?"
So, thank you so much for your time.
- Thank you.
Thanks for, like, giving us a trip
to Chicago cuz I love coming back.
- Nah, I'm sorry it's seven degrees outside, but—
- Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, you gotta bundle up.
- Bundle up for sure.
- Thanks so much, DeMar.
- Thank you.